Trump then says that they presumably  Democrats I guess want to see him in  prison I think they'd like to see me in  prison can you imagine I think that like  you know why you know why because  they're sick they're sick sick people  um one of the things that's interesting  is these Republicans love to say they  are for Law and Order all the time they  say it we're for Law and Order we're for  Law and Order  my position as someone on the left is  not I want to see Trump in prison I'm  out for blood it's if there is evidence  that Trump should be charged then charge  him  and then if he is convicted sentence him  appropriately and maybe that'll include  prison time that's Law and Order  okay not what they claim